[Music]
[Music]
yes welcome
to our today's meeting on the future of
health care for all the adults living in
areas my name is wolfram hermann i'm
professor for channel practice and
health services research at charity
universities medicine berlin which is
part of the berlin university alliance
and i'm very happy to welcome you today
here on site in
natokunda museum in berlin in the birds
room and also online via zoom or via
streaming to our session today it's
going to be one and a half hours about
the future of healthcare for all the
adults
in areas
this is a pressing need in the next 10
to 20 years this topic will be emerging
and be very important
for cities in especially developed
countries and especially berlin and
singapore are going to be cities which
have will have this need to talk about
these topics and thus we are very happy
to have today this joint session between
the national university of singapore and
the berlin university alliance on the
future of healthcare for all the adults
we are going to have four talks by four
professors from berlin and from
singapore on these topics to highlight
different aspects of these topics and
afterwards we'll have time for
discussion
and i'm very much looking forward to
these discussions after the presentation
so first you'll have four presentations
and then there's enough time left for
your questions your comments for your
remarks and your discussions
we will start with the presentation from
the national university of singapore
there will be two professors we are
working together in a project with
we are very delighted to work together
with first is professor angelic chan
she's a sociologist and professor at
duke national university of singapore
medical school and she's the executive
director of the center for aging
research and education
and she will be then accompanied by
professor david mucha who is a
medical doctor and internist he's
professor both at the national
university of singapore and at duke
university in the united states and his
work focuses on health services research
and policy aspects
and i'm very happy to to have these two
here virtually of course because of the
pandemic so we are very much looking
forward to the talk of professor chan
and professor matra from singapore
um
from singapore we have
members online um who are also part of
the project uh dr
vissaria um
dr rocky
and miss nawal
and
the topic is
understanding the health and social
needs of older adults in singapore
so i will start
the first half of the presentation to
give you
context
of singapore
and
the need to really look at health and
social needs of older adults
so
if i could have the next slide please
um if you look at this slide you'll see
that the proportion of the population
age 65 and above
is increasing very rapidly in singapore
which is this this blue line
of course japan will always be ahead of
us
um and interestingly by 2050 south korea
will be ahead of singapore but
there's a very dramatic increase in in
in population aging and it's taking off
as we speak ex almost exponentially next
slide please
and one of the other things that i that
i
like to mention is
the increasing
percentage of the population above the
age of 80.
and the reason i say this is because
currently our life expectancy in
singapore is
roughly 84.3 years
and we see a lot of onset of disability
and dementia
in this oldest old
age group
and they are indeed the fastest growing
segment of the
singapore population at the moment
so i think it's it's important to think
of aging
not as
of the aged not as one lump particular
group but
that there are different needs at
different times
in your life when you are older
now
in singapore we have um
one of the lowest
fertility rates in the world
we reached below replacement total
fertility rate in 1975
and our current fertility rate is 1.1
[Music]
so for those of you who are not
demographers in the audience that means
the average singaporean
only has
one child
um average couple
um
so
in
light of this we also have um an
increase in in total life expectancy
dramatic um
and it's one of the highest in the world
unfortunately this is being accompanied
by
increasing rates of divorce and
non-marriage
increased
female education and employment
and
i mentioned this because it involves
family dynamics and caregiving
and the availability of caregivers
there's also fewer working adults for
older persons aged 65 plus
so fewer younger people because of our
low fertility to support
older people age 65 plus
that's not to say that
older persons in the age group cannot be
productive in and of themselves
but it is reality that they there are
fewer younger people um
[Music]
paying paying taxes
there's also migration out of singapore
it's not a huge problem but but it isn't
it is there
and
so
these changes result in fewer caregivers
available to provide care
and the
research question is how can we fulfill
the health and social care needs of
older persons
in singapore
um next slide please
now one of the things that we know that
living longer does not mean living
longer in better health
um one of the things that we
study is health expectancy so the
analysis of both
healthy and unhealthy years of life
where health can be defined among
various dimensions
and
existing research shows that at age
60
individuals are living longer with worse
health especially women
and this is research that's been done in
singapore and japan
in singapore at age 60 a woman will
spend 77 percent of her remaining years
without disability
compared to a man average singaporean
male will spend 88 percent of his
remaining years without disability so
there are very obvious gender
differences in the health and social
needs of older singaporeans
next slide please
now one of the things that is also
happening is
that
singaporean cohorts
are
changing over time
so what we call the pioneer generation
is a generation of singaporeans who had
very little education
and um
were
not as
are not as healthy as as incoming
cohorts
so
in our projections when we account for
education we find that there are fewer
disabled young old than expected
however
next slide please
our projections show that
because as i mentioned earlier the 80
plus is the fastest growing popular
population in singapore
we expect
more disabled oldest old
than we had originally projected in our
ministry of
health so there's a very urgent need for
integrated care in singapore
particularly for the oldest old next
slide please
so
um
what we need to do and what we want to
do in this project together with
colleagues in berlin
who also are in a very urban environment
is to understand the health and
health-related social needs of older
persons
because we can't design programs without
understanding what their needs are
the second thing is to review the
adequacy of the current healthcare
system to meet these needs
i think this is very important to do a
review
of what's happening now and where are
the gaps
and
the
hope is at the end of the project to
have suggestions of ways to adapt the
health care system
policy and programs to support older
persons in order to prevent and manage
health and social issues
next slide
so this is where i will hand off to
professor david metcher
who is going to talk about how can we
understand
health
and health related social needs in a
population in this case in singapore and
in berlin
over to you david
well thanks uh bachchan so um
this has been a great opportunity to
work with uh with the group in berlin
to deal with an issue which i think is
of common interest
and the work that i'm going to describe
is something that's been going on
between
the center for aging research and
education which is uh the center that
prachan
professor chan uh directs and uh
and my lab which is what we call the
health system design lab um at duke and
us
and it's specifically what we've been uh
focusing on with my group is
is the question how do we assess
needs in a
relatively efficient way
that really captures
the nature of
the service needs that individuals have
and not just the medical needs so a lot
of efforts around
population segmentation have been
oriented towards
how many people have certain diseases or
who are the people who are most likely
to die or who are the people who are
most likely to have very expensive
medical bills
but really um it doesn't get at the
question of what can we do about it what
are the actionable
um what are the things that we can do
that we we can act on
in order to improve the health and
well-being of the population and that
includes both what we traditionally
think of as medical services but also
the social needs which are very strongly
predictive and influential on
health outcomes
so
to give you a little bit of background
from the medical perspective in
singapore one of the things that's
really important to understand is that
singapore developed its
its um
[Music]
public
acute care and advanced care secondary
and tertiary care systems
very
aggressively such that that secondary in
tertiary care
is a part of the public system about 80
percent of services that are
uh in the uh that are that are secondary
in tertiary care
are
and specialty services are in the public
sector whereas uh in in the uh in terms
of primary care primary care has been
left largely historically to
the private sector and the government
has historically had relatively little
influence over the way in which care is
provided and so
there's relatively little communication
or integration between the outpatient
and the inpatient service sides
and one of the things that has
happened as a consequence
is that we've experienced a series of
of problems um which in singapore we
call pain points and the three pain
points that have been
identified consistently have been
some that already
chan has already mentioned which is lack
of intermediate and long-term care
capacity
there have been issues around hospital
bed capacity and the
increasing amount of out-of-pocket costs
that are incurred because in the
singapore health system
even in the public system everyone pays
something it's really part of the
philosophy of of the health system is
that everyone pays something
and so those out of pocket costs even
for the public sector have risen
just to give you an example of
how that pain is manifest
this is a study that one of my phd
students mvphd students in looking at
the way in which hospital beds are being
used
in
in an acute hospital in singapore
and assessed whether how many of the bed
days were being used
for
what it
would be
expected to be acute care needs
okay in other words did they really need
to be in an acute care hospital and from
this side you see pretty vividly that
only about 50 of the days that are bed
days in the hospital were being used for
this older population
for
acute care needs that the other needs
were things that could be done in other
settings potentially less expensive
settings potentially safer settings
where you don't have to worry
necessarily about about uh getting them
[Music]
hospital-acquired infections and so on
and certainly a less expensive place
um
that situation is unsustainable just
we've done some projections looking at
the rates of hospital use and actually
the rates of hospital use per capita for
the older population is actually rising
and we believe that it's rising in large
part because
uh the this this older population as
they get more complex
end up being referred into the public
sector and when they get referred into
the public sector they
naturally flow into the hospital and
tend not to flow out because they don't
have a primary care physician who can
provide this provide services when they
leave
so
we started with this idea about
population segmentation it certainly
wasn't something that our group invented
this was actually
one of the the formative uh
efforts was by
uh joanne lynn and colleagues um in 2007
published a paper looking at
population segmentation based on needs
and called it the bridges to health
model
the basic notion is is that the success
of health and social services
and in fact the the success of the
health care system broadly speaking
which includes health and social
services depends on meeting needs in
fact it's the definition
we meet needs people do better
and
segmentation of the population is based
based on service needs
the intention of this is to promote
three particular
uh
functions one is
to be able to document as professor chan
mentioned the document the needs that
individuals have
both men and none men those are medical
and
and medically related social needs
to be able to identify opportunities for
service innovation based on those
patterns of need and particularly
patterns of unmet
and then it also allows us to more
efficiently evaluate those service
innovations
in terms of how successfully they are
how successfully they do meet those
needs and how successfully they meet
them in a way that is sustainable from
an administrative and economic
perspective
and humane that is to say is something
that is acceptable to the population to
the people who are users of the health
system as well as to the providers of
health services so that they don't burn
in
so we developed a tool this is the first
version that we developed and it's the
version that i i particularly like it's
it's one that's used in a clinical
setting by physicians and nurses it's a
very brief instrument and i'll describe
what it is collected here but it's meant
to be a very
parsimonious a very simple measure
that captures what providers
think of when they think of what makes
this person more or less complex
to take care of and what sorts of
services what level of services that i
need to provide or i need to have a
range i have i need to arrange to have
provided
for this patient so
we it was really very very much oriented
towards trying to be as efficient as
possible and we
in using this instrument we've tested
this on several thousand uh patients
being evaluated by both physicians and
nurses
and showed that this is an instrument
that can be filled in reliably between
physicians and between physicians and
nurses
and that they that that the the results
are very predictive of
longer of outcomes costs so all the
things that you want to have in a
segmentation instrument that i mentioned
earlier but it also allows us to segment
the population into health and social
services and just parenthetically we
also have a version of this that can be
done in a survey setting
and also a version that can be applied
to national data like the ship or
international data like the shared data
which is available in germany
now the concept is that we
think of
needs as uh as operating in two
dimensions the first being the the
medical needs segments and rather than
thinking about uh individuals as falling
into specific disease categories or a
specific conditions we talked about them
in terms of the nature of the services
that we would need to provide to them
in in the traditional health system
ranging from the kinds of things that
you want to provide for a healthy
population which relate to prevention
immunization screening and so on um all
the way to
the palliative services for those people
who are
at
or near end of life
excuse me
and so um each one of these categories
when you describe them to a clinician to
a provider they can generally say yeah i
can give you a i have a general feeling
of what it would be like to take care of
somebody but there's really more to it
than that
in fact there are other needs or other
characteristics that define needs that
individuals have that can make them more
complicated so the second dimension in
this segmentation approach is to look at
these
these needs that are not the traditional
needs provided or addressed by
physicians
first being
adl needs functional deficits and you'll
notice each one of these
generally tends to correspond to a
service that might be provided in order
to alleviate the problems engendered by
that need so functional deficits having
nursing type skill tests and i say
nursing type meaning things like wound
care which could be done by a nurse but
also could potentially be done by a
family member
recording stopped
rehabilitation type services
efforts at organizing care across
multiple providers at multiple locations
lack of activation
in their own in their own care which is
generally the ability for that
individual to manage their own
care recording in progress
whether they need
potentially to have someone provide
services for them so to what extent can
they engage in self-care
do they have disruptive behavioral or
psychiatric issues which can actually
make
caregiving much more complex and also
medical services much more complex and
is associated with substantially higher
healthcare costs
social support in case of need
uh hospital admissions which is not only
a
important because it indicates that this
is a person who has had medical problems
and has had required medical services
but also because people coming in and
out of the hospital
tend to lose connection so there it's an
opportunity to fall through the practice
as the expression goes when they go into
the hospital and then come out of the
hospital and that period of transition
is is a period in which they can have
negative uh
bad outcomes and then finally
polypharmacy which is being on lots of
medications
not only does that mean that that person
might indeed have lots of problems but
also too many drugs
can induce problems so one of the things
that we then did with this was
stopped
one of the things we did with this was
to develop a
a an algorithm
what we call a normative
neet's algorithm which is which takes
the information from this instrument and
then maps it to a series of services and
indeed subdivides it into the kinds of
services that are available in singapore
and could be done
for any other locale where
certain kinds of services may be
available in different ways
but one of the things that was really
interesting about this this using this
tool was that when we evaluated in this
case a thousand patients who were
discharged from the hospital and we we
looked at those people who had
symptomatic chronically symptomatic
conditions and we looked to see whether
they were having
their normative needs met okay so the
instruments suggested at baseline when
they were hospitalized that when they
were discharged they were going to have
certain needs we then evaluated event
three months to see if they had those
needs met
and we had a nurse visit them at their
homes to to see how whether they were
met and then we looked to see how they
did over the over that period from
discharge through one year and as we see
that
individuals who were chronically
symptomatic with chronic conditions who
had all of their needs met and this is
just
one piece of the information they
experienced fewer re-hospitalizations
emergency room visits nursing home
placements and death and that was true
not only for the aggregate outcome free
but also for the each of the individual
outcomes which to some extent should be
gratifying for those of us in the health
care system we believe that we're trying
to do something that that what we're
trying to do
actually accomplishes something
um the other thing that we've been able
to do with this and i'm not going to be
able to have the opportunity to show you
all the things we could do with the
segmentation uh tool but we have been
able to use this in in the context of
simulation modeling in which we've been
able to project future
numbers of individuals with different
levels of health and social service
needs
which is allowing us to identify
whether the projected numbers of
services that would be available going
forward will be adequate to meet those
needs
and so on that i am going to
end and thank you very much
yes so thank you and the applause for
our colleagues in
singapore i'm not sure if it's
transmitted but i hope you can hear the
applause so thank you very much david
and and lick so we are now going on a
german perspective afterwards we want to
discuss all together
as you've already might notice from the
the aspects highlighted by david and
angelique you might have realized there
are many parallelities between berlin
germany and singapore and i want to
highlight some of these in my next
presentation
yes perfect
so
this one does not work
okay so i first want to talk about the
developments
in germany in healthcare system and
demographics then go on to the
challenges for nursing care and channel
practice and finally present some
possible solutions for these problems in
the future of healthcare
do i have to say next slide or
yeah so um you've already seen these
data for singapore and you can see here
the
percentage or the share of person 65
years and older in germany the
projection for the next years and what
you can clearly see there is going to be
from 2020 on so from now on a steep
increase of the share of person 65 years
and older in germany and on the next
slide you can see that
what is about a share of those 80 years
and older and you can see here it's a
bit delayed so it's not going to start
right now but it's going to start in
maybe 5 to 10 years and then there's
going to be a very steep increase of the
share of persons 80 years and older and
what we know is that the demand for
health care and social care and nursing
care of those eight years and older is
the highest in the population so we're
going to look forward to steep increase
of health care demand in the next 10 20
years and we need to be prepared for
that and that's why we are doing this
project together because it's not only
we in germany we have to be prepared but
it's also people are the healthcare
system in singapore but we can have a
look on the broader level so in global
health perspective it's in many states
and cities worldwide where we have to
have to be prepared for
this increase of health care needs if we
go to the next slide
you can see looking in germany that the
share of people living in urban areas
has been increasing since the 1950s so
singapore is a totally urbanized state
but you can see also in germany most
people live in cities and if you have a
look on the next slide you can see um
that this share is mainly in middle
sized cities so in gray you can see
those up to 300 000 inhabitants so there
is a larger increase and in purple you
can see where berlin belongs to one to
five million inhabitants this part is
also going to increase
in the next years
so it's not only the very large cities
but also the middle cities which will
have an increase in the population
next slide please
so what does it mean then for nursing
care the next slide you can see the need
for care the prevalence in germany by
age groups so you see that the age group
of 90 years the red one has a very high
prevalence of the need for care
it's more than 70 lately in the latest
numbers so you can see here a clear age
dependence on a need for care
this is by the
care insurance data and if we have a
look on berlin that's the next slide
you can see there is not a big
difference between berlin and germany
regarding the need for care in the
different age groups so it's mainly age
dependent and there is not a big big
difference between berlin and the rest
of germany if we look at the next slide
we can see so where are people who have
now we are looking at those who have a
need for care
where do they live and we see that a bit
less than twenty percent live in nursing
homes which means what you see in the
next slide that more than eighty percent
live at home and now who is taking care
of those living at home which is the
vast majority and the next slide we see
that only a smaller part about 25
percent of the whole population
has ambulatory nursing care of this
population needing care so we can see
that two-thirds of those living at home
do not receive ambulatory nursing care
but are mainly and that's on the next
slide
without professional nursing care at all
so it's mainly relatives here taking
care of these
it's either the spouse usually or the
children and we can compare it now the
next slide with berlin and you can see
again here is not a big difference
between berlin and the rest of germany
so it's more or less the same
the same shares and the same figures
if we now go on
what is different in berlin and
especially in urban areas
is that the family structure is
different from what we are used to
somehow to say so we see in berlin
about a third of all adults live alone
that's more than half of all households
so more than half of all households in
berlin are single households with just
one person living in these
and you can see if we are the increasing
age the share of those who live alone is
increasing so if we look at the age
group 85 plus it's already two-thirds of
persons living alone at home so there's
no spouse or no children living with
them
and this will also will be further
increase in the future we expect it to
increase in the future if you look now
at the families at the moment there are
many children running around here also
in this museum here so if we look at
berlin all women who have uh underage
children so children up till the age of
17 one fourth of them is a lone parent
and it's about four percent of the male
of the fathers who are alone parents and
this is much higher than in the rest of
germany so we see um the family
structure this typical
maybe idealistic family structure we
always think of father mother and
several children this is just not just
not the case anymore in berlin so we
have many lone parents we have many
people without children we have
patchwork families so we have many
different family structures and this is
a challenge for this care which is right
now done mainly by relatives so if we go
on the next slide
do we need more professional nursing
care then so that's a big question i
think everyone from germany knows
because it has been very much in the
media lately
that professional nursing care in
germany but not in germany but in most
countries in the world to
be exactly is a problem especially what
we see in germany is a very low job
satisfaction for nurses so that's
something more germany specific the job
satisfaction is very low many nurses
drop out of their job
however we have more nurses than in many
other countries especially interestingly
male nurses like in the us we have one
to two percent male nurses um in germany
we are soon
hitting equality here
but the distribution is very sub-optimal
so we have
like in
singapore people are very often in the
hospital so we have many hospital stays
and long hospital stays and there's a
this is a big parallel to the
singaporean system where it's the same
so we have high load in tertiary care
and this binds many nurses um
so there is there are less nurses for
the distribution left for ambulatory
care and something additionally if you
look at nursing homes in berlin you can
see that we have 357 nursing homes um
caring for older adults
and you can here have a look on this on
the size of these nursing homes so the
majority of those are up to 50 or maybe
up to 100
clients so they are quite small
comparatively and if we look at
ambulatory nursing care facilities you
can see that we have 634 of these
ambulatory nursing care facilities and
they usually have very few clients some
have just up to 10 clients but the
majority is a maximum of 50 clients
so first of all this looks nice because
there's some competition there's to
choose from the ambulatory nursing care
however what does it mean working
together so a gp practice having all the
adults working together caring for them
which wants to work together with
ambulatory care services this means in
berlin in this fragmented system that
you have not one ambulatory healthcare
service like for example in norway you
work together with and you can talk
about the patients but you have seven
eight nine ten different um ambulatory
nursing facilities you should work
together with and this somehow leads to
that you don't work together close with
any of those because it's just too
fragmented and too difficult to know who
is now the nurse taking care of our
patient
so next slide please
so what does it mean we see there will
be an increasing demand for care because
of the demographic change but also
because of change in the family
structure
we see right now in germany we have a
sub-optimal allocation of nurses and we
have too few nurses and a declining
interest in nursing as a job this would
be a whole talk on itself to talk about
these topics but it's important for
health care of the future and we see
this fragmented system with no
cooperation between or nearly no
cooperation between nurses and gps
so
that's about the challenge in nursing
care what's about the challenge in gp
care on the next slide
and again
so
what is typical for gp practices in
germany they are usually solely run
that's not um they are privately run and
they are very small so um
this is like the same as in singapore as
we just heard so that's also very
interesting parallel um but in many
countries it's different so in germany
we have very small practices you can see
that we have in germany's twenty seven
thousand more than twenty seven thousand
single hand practices compared to just
eight thousand eight hundred multi-hand
practices and even those multi-hunt
practices usually have just two to three
gps if we have a look at other countries
it's usually that there are 10 10 gps or
so working together in primary health
care centers that's not common in
germany
it's very
rarely that
specialists and gps mixing these
practices is just 700.
what's growing are larger entities so
called emphatic for the germans in the
audience
however these do not really mean that
they are one working in one practice
site but often they are split over many
different practices so they are just
organizationally and bureaucratically
one practice but really working together
they are split up in smaller units so
you cannot really say they are
integrated care units
and another very typical german aspect
and maybe the most typical german aspect
evolutory care you can see um down here
and for in berlin it's even more
pronounced than in the rest of germany
we have in berlin
nearly 3 000 gps however in ambulatory
care only talking about ambulatory care
but we have more than 7000 other
specialists so it's about one-third of
gps and two-thirds of other specialists
and this is very special compared to
other countries in most countries there
are even no specialists work in
ambulatory care they work in outpatient
clinics at the hospitals giving
outpatient service but it's very
uncommon to have ophthalmologists in
their own practice or a rheumatologist
in their own practice or cardiologists
in their own practice so this is typical
germany and here in berlin it's
especially pronounced so here we have
many many specialists working in their
own practices compared to few gps and
way too few gps coming new so in berlin
we have about 70
young new gps graduating per year and we
need at least double to
to refill those we already have and what
we already have is from this point we
are looking on the future of healthcare
it's not enough but we kill we cannot
fill um the amount of gps we need for
the state at the moment and
not at all for the future what we need
in the future so this is going to be a
big problem
we go to the next slide
another thing is that gps in berlin are
very sub-optimal distributed so we have
too few but also these few tend to
agglomerate in parts where rich people
live and less in parts where poor people
live so you can see here that's the
neighborhood clickstrategy you can see
it the small red
[Music]
region on the left upper side of the map
and there live eight more than eight
thousand habitants and more than one
thousand 300 older adults living there
however in this neighborhood there is no
gp at all
and there is no health care facility
there only a dentist
and then students of mine went there in
this neighborhood and asked people on
the street do you live here and if they
said yes they asked where's your gp and
they mapped it here um on this map and
so you can see the distribution very gps
are located of the people living locally
there
is very far apart so that's very
interesting we go on the next slide
another problem we have is the low flow
of information so you've already heard
in the presentations from singapore that
it's about complex needs
and what we have in germany we have many
specialists but the specialists in the
gps the flow of information is not very
good you can see here a phd sees this um
of a student of mine
who asked the gps where how often do
they get an answer if they have a
referral to a specialist how often do
they get a letter back with information
what happened there and you can see here
that from gynecology you nearly get
never an answer the same with
dermatology of hepatic psychiatry ent
and ophthalmologist only the internal
medicine disciplines like cardiology and
gastroenterology day sent
letters back but from the others if you
refer a patient to these
to these specialties you usually never
get any letter back so you have no
information what happens there with
these specialists
you can go on the next slide
so this is what i want to prepare you is
for the fragmentation in the german
healthcare system and here is real data
from
a german healthcare insurance so this is
a 70 year old woman and we would say her
care is not fragmented you can see it's
2011 to 2015. every dot is a
consultation with a
doctor and on the y-axis you see the
different doctors
and you can see she's very steadily with
her internist as primary care physician
and only very few times with other
specialists but very often she is in the
pharmacy um to get her medication to
receive her medication but now we can
have a look at the next slide
and this is another real world example
so this is a
69 year old woman also over the course
of five years and you can see she is
within orange with many different gps
and she's also changing them regularly
so in the middle of 2012 so first she is
with two gps then she changes is with
another two gps for the next three years
then changes again so with one gp and
chase again with another gp so it's
visiting many different gps but she's
not only visiting many different gps but
you cannot read it but you can see every
every um on the y-axis every line is
another physician so this is many
different physicians with five or more
ophthalmologists with different
urologists
nuclear medicine doctors etc etc and you
can see all these
lines of referrals so they're very often
referrals
and
however it's very clear this is
extremely fragmented no one i don't
think even herself can say what happened
there so if for example she is coming
into my practice in the middle of 2014
as a new patient and i ask her oh what
has been happening to you in the health
care system in the last
one two three years i think she cannot
tell and no one can tell and even if
you're looking about for the german
audience about the electronic patient
records
this wouldn't help here because the
electronic patient records would be
extremely large and you need at least
some technical digital possibility to to
search it to find somehow the
information you need okay so i think
this picture shows the problem again we
see here the numbers for example
patients with heart failure in germany
over five years with it 15 different
doctors and also three different gps
over the five years and they see 140 80
48 times a doctor that means 30 doctor
visits a year so more than every second
week people with heart failure visit the
doctor in ambulatory care system in
germany and 17 times a year gp so every
third week they see their gp so they are
very often there and this leads to the
typical germ thing that the
consultations itself are very very short
so
like four or five minutes for example
with autopedic surgeon in his or her
practice
so this is then together linked with
this fragmentation so
go to next slide
and a last thing i want to add and you
already have seen it in the presentation
by david there are social core problems
which right now in our healthcare system
we ignore um so we there is there are
studies showing that gps have very
frequent social co-problems like
problems at work financial problems um
problems in their family in their social
life loneliness is a very typical social
problem for all the adults we know also
in berlin is quite frequent
however there is also in berlin there is
there are many offers and counseling
offers but they are totally separate
from the medical healthcare system
and people do not know from each other
so to somehow summarize here we see
there is a core problem in the german
healthcare system which in my opinion
but by um i think by these studies you
can see it quite clearly that we
give a demand a highloid high load of
organization from the patient so the
patient has to give the information as
there is no information flowing the
patient have to keep track of all this
fragmented health care and has to find
his or her way to all these services
this works quite well for
for highly educated
persons these are fit privileged younger
people people who studied
etc who have a phd they usually can do
this however those who are vulnerable
who have problems in writing in reading
who have maybe language difficulties who
have a very low socio-economic status
and so those who would need our help on
the help of the health care system most
they struggle with this because they are
not able to do it they are not able to
find the appointments and to transport
the information and this is a main
problem major problem in our german
health care system so if we go next
i want to
sum up the challenges but i think i've
said everything here
already
hospital care and specialist care
dominates there's a lack of inflow of
information and coordination we have
over utilization especially in the
tertiary sector the same as in singapore
and
no corporation no community orientation
so now next we see
what might be possible solutions
the next slide
so i want to just very roughly present
you
two to three aspects for discussion and
also later on social prescribing on the
next slide
is the first
option
which is from the uk so i highlighted
our patients with psychosocial problems
and in the next slide we see they are
coming to the gp
and we know from studies that people
with low socioeconomic status are very
often coming to the gp so next slide and
again the next one already
and the idea for social prescribing is
that now we can
fill such a social prescribed usually
they come to us and we can say oh maybe
you can have a look for counselling or
we send them home or we send them to the
hospital
now we will have the possibility to have
a social prescription and the link
worker is then going to place them with
the local providers of psychosocial
health which are already there so they
are there we don't have to create them
but they are there and then
the patient gets help with this
so that's a very nice model in build up
in the uk and what we did is we did a
systematic review on the next slide you
can see the flow here
on the effectiveness
and efficacy of these
interventions and i just want to
highlight a few aspects of this on the
next slide you can see it's very small
so you just have to believe what i'm
going to say but it's going to be
published hopefully very soon as well
so we can see predominantly positive
effects on mental health here also we
have to say if you look at the two
very broad
confidence intervals here you can see
that the randomized control trials did
not really show very positive effects so
it's more
lower evidence study so that's a bit of
problem and you can also see on mental
well-being that's the second part
positive effects of these social
prescribing interventions on the next
slide we look on loneliness which is
very important in for all the adults and
quality of life and you can see also in
loneliness there have been positive
effects um
this very broad one with no effect was
just with certain people so we wouldn't
expect here to show any effect by the
number of participants anyway and also
quality of life you can see a positive
tendency and also not all studies showed
a significant effect
and
the next slide you can see the third
question which is also from a health
services perspective important
does it save money is it cost effective
and here you can see that in the upper
part primary care utilization
goes lower so people have them to go
less often to the gp but more important
on the downside or on the lower part you
can see emergency department visits and
this is very important so with social
prescribing emergency department visits
um drop less a bit less but they are
less and that's something which can save
much money and uh
yeah so it's very positive
so we see here social prescribing might
be an option and if you go on the next
slide
and another one
the advantage of social prescribing is
that we can just use the system as it is
so we do not we only need a link worker
and a social prescription however you
might think further and say that's not
enough we need to strengthen primary
care because we need as we have in other
countries integrated community oriented
care centers with more doctors working
in them inter-professionally with others
not only channel practitioners but we
need nurses working there together we
need social workers working there
together maybe physiotherapists
agrotherapists occupation therapists and
others working closely together with a
strict community orientation so we work
in a neighborhood for example in berlin
and have a community we are responsible
for and for those all the adults and all
adults but especially all the adults
living in these areas
and then we can work together with the
local stakeholders
this will need systemic changes and
that's the last thing i want to
highlight for today for just this short
impression i want to give
if we want to implement such more
innovative organizational care
organizations then we need that we need
to change our hospital care hospitals in
the future need to be focused more on
intense high-tech care what they are
best
what they're able to do best
so this means we need less hospitals and
less hospital stays because only people
who need intense care will in the future
go to hospitals and not just for
dehydration for example
we will need that the specialist care
focuses on what they can do best what
they can do best is care for severe and
complex cases consulting also gps and
then working together with the gps
this also means that we need more gps
because then they have to do more so we
need more gps we have to attract the
young medical students to bgps and these
gps need then longer and less frequent
consultations
with the patients so gp patient
consultations have to be less but then
longer so we have if we have half an
hour with a patient i don't have to see
this patient every second week so we
need to change our healthcare system and
how could we do this and now that's why
working together with singapore is so
important we have to do this needs based
and that's where the singapore
what in singapore developed sst as david
presented it comes in play so to need to
have these needs
to assess we need this singer this
segmentation scheme
the colleagues developed and at the
moment we are
applying this segmentation scheme for
survey data we have in berlin at the
moment we're in plausibility tests
and we hope that soon we will have also
results to show how are the needs
distributed in berlin and how are they
locally different so if there are there
in different neighborhoods in berlin the
needs
different so do we and so we can then
later on account for that in planning
healthcare locally
so this is what i wanted to present you
today
and now i want to hand over to paul
gellar who is going to highlight a
different aspect of
health and health of the elderly
which is mobility
[Applause]
yeah hello everybody
where are my slides
so i'm going to talk about mobility in
old age but i'm just waiting for my
slides
so it's about mobility in old age for
accessing
healthcare and for social participation
in urban but also in rural areas so my
name is paul gellard i'm a professor of
social and behavioral genetology at
charity but and a trained health
psychologist next slide please
so but what is mobility at least in our
presentation in our research mobility
next slide please
mobility is the movement to plan and
execute activities inside the person's
acting area on their own while adjusting
to environmental factors next
but when we talk about mobility then we
also have to distinguish certain
type of concepts so the broadest concept
is the life space mobility which
basically is the spatial extent of a
person's
acting area
then there's a then there's a more
narrow
concept of which is physical activity
which can be mild moderate or vigorous
and can be home activities
work activities travel activities or
sports
and then there's walking which also can
be
slow or brisk and which is very
important in your daily routine
especially when you
investigate um thank you
when you investigate uh older adults
mobility
then there are a lot of
prerequisites for mobility
there's several organ systems that have
to work together to be physically active
so we need the brain for movement
initiation and coordination
we need the nerves the muscles
several receptors and we also need the
cardiovascular system and the
respiratory systems for energy supply
and when you think about diseases and of
course it's
clear that if a disease affects one or
several of these organ systems then it
may also affect your mobility
other way around if you live a active
life then of course this will be
preventive for many of these diseases
and why else is mobility so important
here we see
data from our own study we asked people
over 60 years of age about their
mobility biography and what we have
found is that of the people who are
constantly inactive across the life
course
the people who decrease the activity
over the lifespan there are people who
increase
the activity and there are some people
who are constantly active
and what we found is that these uh
activity levels especially the increased
activity and the constantly active uh
people they were this was related to
well-being to aging satisfaction
to positive mood and to better mental
and physical health
and as other research has shown that
there are some intermediating factors
which means that access to health care
and social participation are between
these two concepts
but how we do assess
life space mobility so there's a concept
of baker and colleagues and she uses the
life's life
space approach and distinguish several
levels of life space so that's the room
or the house
the garden or the neighborhood
the community or the city
or even beyond
and there are two types of
different measures that we
have been using so there's
something broken yeah so that's a the
live space assessment it's basically a
questionnaire where we ask people to
indicate uh their physical their their
life space on a questionnaire basis so
the the former version was from baker
2003 the english version but then our
group translated this one and validated
this one into a german version and then
as of course
the global positioning system so every
time you take your mobile and it's
talking with the satellite and
receiving your position and of course
you could use this information for your
life space mobility
and there are two studies that i want to
present
data from and the first one is the psych
care studies
was located in berlin
we finished this study
recently
and we collected data from 197
community dwelling all the adults with
care needs so they had all afflicted in
germany and the clinical depression so
it's a very vulnerable and fragile
population
and
we asked them about their with the
questionnaire we asked them about their
life space and of course this life space
was very very much restricted some
people
not even left their room
and we found that depressive symptoms
and functional limitations were the most
predictive
indicators for
restricted life
space in this population so the
depressive symptoms related to drive to
motivation to mood of course limit the
life space and the functional
limitations are related to a
physical decline of physical limitations
of course there's a physical component
when we talk about life space
mobility but then there's also living
alone was
my from mentioned already that
loneliness is an important factor in old
age so loneliness was also here very
much uh
related to live space but then on the
other side livespace was also
related to primary care use and also to
psychiatrist use so if there was the the
life space was lower then also the
primary care access and the psychiatrist
access was lower in this people with
clinical depression we have to say and
with care needs
and what we also found that there was
no relation to
psychotherapy use but we know also that
the rates of psychotherapy use are very
very low in this population
in this population with urgent needs
and there's a second study i want to
present data on and as you can see it's
not
taking part in berlin but near berlin in
the hafeland it's a very nice region in
brandenburg near berlin and there are
about 160 000 inhabitants in this very
very large area
and the western part is predominantly
agriculture middle class and
populated by an age population and
compared to this the eastern part near
berlin it's
urban suburban and are also small towns
and the most uh famous thing in hafland
is the the poem of the nobleman of
hefner rebecc and his pear tree so the
the story is that uh the
heaven rebecca gave pears to children
and when he died a pear tree grew on his
grave
and there's also as we also heard in the
other talks there's accelerated
population aging
because of rural depopulation low birth
rates and also low migration
and the healthcare has to take part
across long distances especially in the
rural part of this
this area and there's also a shortage of
gps and not
nursing projected in the future
and here we see a map of the hoverland
on the right hand side that's near
berlin on the left-hand side it's more
the rural part and the green areas are
those with a low density
of people living there and what you see
here is the the difference in the in the
coming years and what we see is that the
blue areas means that even people move
move away or die away in this area so
that's the density becomes even less
well this is there's an increase in this
in the suburban and
small town areas near berlin
and if we correlate this with the
structure of the of the aging
in the age structure of the
population and we see that
of course in rural areas there are also
more older individuals for instance here
in in the
in one of the rural areas that 32
of the population are age 35 and older
well this is only 14 when we look into
the areas near berlin
so actually just these are all slides so
um
so therefore i i just skipped this
um i don't know why this happens
um
then i would talk about the mobile
project what we did there is we looked
into mobility and old dashboard
integrating healthcare and personal
network resources and other adults
living in rural areas but also in this
areas near
berlin and compare them so the goals
where to describe and to improve the
mobility by
fostering personal social and
environmental
resources
and we focused on people 75 plus and
they were from this
suburban areas and but also from the
rural areas and we included people with
and without frailty syndrome is a
syndrome which is related with
mobility restrictions
and we ran a cluster randomized control
trial rct so it's an ongoing try we plan
to it basically means that we plan to
include 254 participants at the moment
we have a bit more than 100
participants included and survey them on
different types of resources
and also we trace them with jeep with
gps
and
half of this participants will randomly
receive an intervention which is
a preventive home visit by
physiotherapists
and
um yeah so here we see one participant
um
walking next to a lake
so sorry it's old i have old slides so
therefore i don't know uh the order
really um and here we see uh part of the
parts of the um
[Music]
part of the intervention so the
intervention is a preventive home visit
which means a physiotherapist is coming
to the people people's home and they
have a conversation about different
types of resources there's one type of
resources are personal resources so they
set mobility goals then there's a type
of resources which we call social
resources
that people create a network
map where all people who are important
for the mobility of the individual
professional resources but also
friends or neighbors and family members
were included and then we find gaps in
this
network and
potentially also solutions and then also
a regional resource map where all the
important healthcare professionals are
can be allocated to the personal and the
social resources
this is how it looks like so the
therapist is coming has a tablet on
board so there's
a app that we programmed in this project
and then we have a face-to-face
counseling
session talk about the interpersonal
goal setting the network map and also
the regional resources
and then the people will be traced for
for seven days then we have a break for
one month and then we trace them again
for
seven days and there are
many of these follow-ups over a period
of one year
and here we see some some pictures from
from the gps tracking from the
baseline from the baseline and from the
pilot part of the study so here we
make a
visit to our colleagues from technical
university who's familiar with this map
they also programmed all the technical
uh features of our study
and then you make a trip to
the huffle and from berlin
again the the picture of the lake
and here
my last slide so this is a trip to
the village of ribeck where the ribeck
castle is placed and also where the
grave of the nobleman ribbik is and
where all the beautiful pierced pier
trace
trees are
okay thank you for attention
yeah maybe you stay
thank you very much paul um and i hope
now we have time for 25 minutes uh for
uh discussion questions um and i hope we
can see now the um colleagues from
singapore on the screen so you have
possibilities you can put your question
into the zoom
zoom
chat you can post them by hand in zoom
hopefully and or you can have a question
here
in the audience on site but maybe we
should wait can we have the zoom
to see the colleagues that would be
great
well friend we've had some nice
questions on the zoom chat already
i don't know if you can see the zoom
chat but
there have been some questions
that have come in
i think do you phillip you have do you
have them
so
um maybe maybe you can i cannot see them
unfortunately but maybe you can read one
out and then we can talk about it
angelique
ah okay um
okay
the
recording in progress
recording stopped
[Music]
so as you can see it's our first uh
hybrid uh session like this part so it's
a bit technically we have to train you
things so that's also very interesting
so i'm sorry for this delay but i hope
um we can still
soon go on with the um
discussion maybe in the meanwhile
i i have the questions in front of me if
you'd like me to ask the questions and
then
whoever can answer them can answer it so
the first question was about
asking about singapore
about gender
differences and disabilities
and
i guess the question really looks like
it's about whether
um
where do the general gender differences
uh and disability come from
um and and then you you did actually
have an answer on the line which said
uh
that you thought it might be genetic and
also men to engage in morbid dangerous
behaviors
and i guess i would add to that answer
that women also
are more susceptible to
um
to
orthopedic issues to to joint and bone
problems so
musculoskeletal problems are more common
in women and
can be very restricted so
i don't know if you have any other
answers to that the gender difference
question
no no i don't i mean this is this is a
question that has been
i mean everyone is trying to understand
why why this difference exists and i
think the max planck institute has been
doing a lot of work on this
um
but uh here
yeah we just
don't really have
an explanation at the moment
other than
men engage in riskier behaviors over the
lifetime they live shorter so they have
fewer years to have disability
then there was a question i think that
related to
the segmentation which was the nursing
type skill task
and i i think i sort of tried to answer
it on the chat but basically
um we have been looking at whether
meeting specific types of needs so
there's a list of 12 potential needs and
we're trying to identify which of those
needs are more seem to be more important
to me
and the ones that seem what that seem to
be perking up is the most important is
supervisory services that a supervisory
care seems to substantially that those
people who are being to be candidates
for supervisory care do
significantly better if they have
if they receive those kinds of services
uh nursing type services were more
complicated they um they certainly are
predictive of people who do
worse because those people who require
wound care urinary catheter care
nasogastric tube care and so on um
generally are
sicker people irrespective of what their
global impression category is
and there do seem to be some
some types of nursing services that were
more likely to be associated with better
outcomes but we're still
looking at that
and i think
about these complicating factors what i
think they are also practically like
from a gp perspective they are very
important because um having these
complicating factors makes the primary
care just much more difficult because
you not only have the disease
in the global impression but you also
have these extra complicating factors
and that's what's consuming and
especially for coordinating these
different services which makes them very
difficult
the next question david do you want to
read it out
okay so uh what are approaches to
substitute informal care provided by
family members
another one before that could you
elaborate on i'll elaborate on expected
benefits uh from a backflow from from
specialists to gps in germany you cannot
circumvent the gp visit because uh
because you have to first go to uh gp
before you go to a specialist
um
that's a great question and certainly
relevant in singapore um there is
certainly a lot of effort in singapore
to uh
well
the question is he asked about germany
so i'm going to refer back to herman
i can tell you about singapore well
maybe first the singapore perspective
that's fine
okay well the singapore perspective
basically is is that um
that uh it seems to make both the gps
and the specialists unhappy uh because
it hasn't they haven't figured out how
to they're in the process of figuring
out how to do how to do it in a way that
makes financial sense so it's not so
much it and also that it makes
sense in terms of
of workload so if you take
patients who are being seen by a
specialist and refer them back to a gp
in singapore the gps are often
very overloaded and they're seeing maybe
one patient every five minutes and so if
you take a modestly complicated patient
and give them to a gp
then you just overlook you just
overwhelm them so you end up with an
unhappy gp but you also may end up with
an unhappy specialist who may have key
performance indicators because they're
in the public sector which is they have
to see a certain volume of patients and
so if they take their simpler patients
and give them to the gps
then
they then all the patients that they're
seeing are the complicated patients so
it makes their lives more complicated so
it's an interesting dynamic and i think
the only the way to solve it will have
to be
making sure that there's a balance in
the numbers of providers
um and that
and that that their that whatever
financial losses might accrue as a
result of this this flow um are are
taking into account through the through
the funding system
yeah i think i'm not sure if i got
acoustically the whole question but but
i think it was about the the working
together of gps and specialists and um
so why is the distribution in germany so
difficult because um well there are
different aspects of course financially
so a big part of the money flows into a
specialist system um where it might be
more cost effective
in the primary care system because we
know usually from also the studies from
baba starfield that money spent in
primary care system uh has a larger
effect on the health of these persons
and specialist care is just also more
expensive than primary care
and um of course it also the another
problem is that in the
healthcare system in germany as it is
the specialists do
many things but you know they are they i
think for them it would be also more
rewarding to focus on the complex
patients uh who really need their help
but at the moment for example if you
look at orthopedic
and orthopedic surgeons or the doctors
in the ambulatory care system
they have in berlin to pay nearly a
million euros to to buy such a practice
and then
to they have somehow to get this money
back and what they do is they see
patients patients patients about four
minutes
maybe each patient and it's very clear
in four minutes you cannot focus on any
real orthopedic problems and give any
real advice but it's just you know
coming in getting the numbers getting
the icd code and getting maybe some
medication or some injection or so and
then
going to the next patient
and that's not what really anyone
benefits from you know
especially for example then you just
mentioned with the medication then the
patient has another medication but the
primary care physician never hears about
her hears about it if not the patient
tells them and then there are for
example um
interactions of course so that all the
typical pain medications have
interactions with for example all the
heart medications we have in general
practice but we do not know about it
because we never heard here that the
patient gets ibuprofen and then we have
should say tell the patient oh yeah but
you cannot take ibuprofen
in the eight hours before you take your
aspirin and et cetera so um there are
many small and bigger problems with this
that's why i think it's it would be for
both sides very well if the specialists
focused on their real specialist care
i think they're also not very happy
about these four-minute consultations
and the longitudinal basic
but also complex care would stay in the
gp practice however this would mean of
course on the health care level that we
in the future that the number of
specialists have to go down and the
number of gps has to increase
and that's of course something the
specialists do not want
and actual of course understandable in
the system
is there maybe a question here in the
audience now we had from the chat
anyone a question here in the audience
yeah we have a microphone
um
hello do you think that the three
choices of the patients so if i want to
go to a specialist i go to a specialist
and if this
doesn't
if
i'm sorry and if that's not enough i go
to the next one and then i go back to my
gp and if this isn't enough i go to the
next do you think that it should be
limited how many
specialists and gps i can with it as a
patient
so
that the
fragmented
patient history isn't so much
you know what i mean yeah yeah it's that
they're different i'm not sure maybe
maybe afterwards the colleagues from
singapore can add how it's regulated in
singapore so in germany there's no
there's no regulation you can go to any
doctor and the regulation is somehow
done by the doctors
how many patients they accept and the
waiting times
in in most countries in the world it's
like you first have to go to gp and need
a referral by the gp to go
to the doctor
this has some advantages for example so
a typical also practical case i saw
myself working orthopedic care is that
someone comes to our orthopedic clinic
ambulatory clinic
and tells yeah he has a back pain for
now three weeks like a wheel around his
his his breast and pressing and it's so
hurtful and especially when he's walking
and then as
back from ncp my the red flag is coming
up and i said you go now directly to the
gp on the other side of the street and
then he went there and later on he came
back some days later and said oh thank
you it was a myocardial infarction which
happened some time before but he thought
himself it's back pain i have to go to
the other paddock sergeant and that's
what he did and that's
not very in this case it was not that
harmful because it was okay you know you
could still do the intervention but
maybe would have been better earlier on
so it's not always the patient who is
best to decide where to go because there
might be wrong
ideas so i think that's why such a
referral system might be very helpful
the question if you should regulate a
number of
physicians that's very interesting
i'm only aware that in norway there you
have a list system you have to to what's
common is a list system that you have to
register with the gp and then you're in
the list of this gp
and there you can change twice a year i
think that's so if you wanted to that's
the maximum you can do you can change
the list and you can change as far as i
know a maximum of try two times a year
so that's how then there is some
regulation and they also have this
referral scheme so you need a referral
to go to a specialist so those two
things being enlisted with the gps and
mandatory referrals they keep the
numbers lower and might be very helpful
but they at the moment i think in the
public in germany they are not really um
it's very difficult to to
to um
to convince the public that this is
necessary i'm not sure how do you do in
singapore are there any limitations do
you need a referral to go to a
specialist
yes so
yeah
that in order to get a subsidized um
[Music]
fee for a public so most of most of the
specialist services are
in the private sector and in the public
sector so if you want to go to a gp i
mean if you want to go to a specialist
um you you need to get a referral you
can go to the private sector and it just
is expensive and you pay out of pocket
um so that is its own has its own set of
issues and there is a a small insurance
system so you all have much more um
insurance coverage than than you do in
singapore private insurance
um so what happens is then um that the
gp the patient ends up going to the gp
just to get the referral
so it's literally just a referral visit
um it's it's almost
i mean it becomes very difficult for
uh for somebody who's only going to have
five minutes to see you to be able to
make much of an assessment about whether
you're
you know whether you know your
particular problem does it you know your
chest pain should or shouldn't be seen
by a cardiologist because you know
basically the the
the generalists are very risk averse
understandably especially when they're
very time constrained so i think
you know the idea of having uh
having so
so having a
uh
a system where your
your site of first care is going to be a
generalist makes a lot of sense but the
generalist has to have the capacity both
in terms of time and training
and one of the other things that's
happening in singapore that is is likely
to shift is or is definitely shifting is
the level of training expected for
uh primary care physicians is increasing
so you can't just come out of medical
school and be a general practitioner you
you will eventually in order to get any
kind of stuff uh be
able to become uh contracted for any
sorts of services will need to have some
higher level of training and they now
have a family medicine registry which is
i think what what will ultimately be um
how that's dealt with yeah yeah i think
about the referral
it's always very interesting for me to
astonishing to see the parallels because
here it's the same we had before some
sort of referral
scheme in germany as well and then it
was
and so that's the downside more or less
the same that people just go to the to
the entrance and work with the secretary
there and then they already get the
referral because the gps do not have the
capacity
to to talk with the patients if it's
really necessary so i think that's a
very important point you highlight here
that if we implement something like this
we also need a higher capacity and
possibility for this first point of
contact to also deal with these medical
problems and at the moment we do not
really have this capacity neither in
singapore nor in berlin
and that's also
part of the problem of
course are there any further questions
in the chat or here in in the audience
yeah there's another question in the
audience
uh what do you think
for instance about the project of world
health organization and the label for
communities or citizens
for old
[Music]
old age
communities
there there are rules to
attain
in citizens or communities the old aged
persons
and this includes meetings
infrastructure
etc
to reach a well-being of the old persons
what do you think about it
thank you
yeah i think that there are by the who
um
abroad like the healthy city projects
but also about uh old age in cities and
i think they are very important
approaches from a different perspective
so not from the healthcare perspectives
but from the community perspective and i
know also in berlin some of the um so in
berlin this is decentralized so the
betsyka are responsible for these
aspects and many of these try to for
example lichtenberg try to implement
interventions to um
sorry there's just someone coming in
with some nice art so um
trying to to implement such uh measures
and i think that's very important what
we need more is to to have this um
bound together so at the moment at least
in germany it's it's very separate so we
have this community health perspective
um the batiaco with qpk
working there and the health authorities
working there and we have the local
health services but they are they have
no interaction they have no connection
and no flow of information and i think
that's something where we have here try
to close this gap and what we are trying
to establish also like in in our
projects here also in this poor context
to work together with the the local
administrative
bodies because i think it's important
that we start talking together and start
to try to close this gap so i think it's
very important to look on the community
level because that's where health the
main part of health is made also in a
preventive way
so it's better to work there than stream
downstream in the healthcare system but
it should be somehow connected and i
think that's going to be um the big
challenge one of the big challenges also
for the future because in germany this
is very separate so there is no
interaction between community health and
the health care system
i'm not sure how how is it in singapore
how would you describe the the
cooperation between community health and
the health care system
and primary care
answer that in terms of
and i can give you a little bit of an
insight in terms of
um i mean there is some effort in the in
the public sector to develop uh there is
something called the agency for
integrated care which is making an
effort to
create a um
you know a vehicle for
for making more standard referrals to
community-based services um but i think
that its reach is fairly it's still
fairly limited um i don't think that
it's it really constitutes kind of a
very enriched
environment in which in which uh
you know primary care physicians can
make referrals for social service care
uh very easily i think that that's still
something that needs to be developed
i
i
agree with that david i think a lot of
the community care services at the
moment in singapore i mean we're a small
country
have traditionally been been done by
ngos
and there are pilots now being
undertaken in singapore to embed nurses
and
nurse practitioners within
communities
during the week
to help patients who have been
discharged
up to six months after discharge to
manage their conditions
and to help patients with
medication management
pain management and any other issues
they may have with adl and iadl
activities but we have not got it
perfected
there are still many issues that we need
to tweak
but
singapore is definitely trying to build
up community health services
uh
in the next five years
yeah thank you thank you very much i
think that it gives a good comparison
and i think that's maybe as we are
coming to the end of this this session i
think that that's uh maybe the take-home
message for you or the very interesting
thing is
for at least for me and still
astonishing as i already said that we
are struggling with very similar
problems also the healthcare systems are
quite differently organized in finance
between singapore and germany and berlin
but the problems and the challenges for
the future are very similar and i think
that's why we are trying or want to do
work together in this berlin university
alliance project to look for the needs
of the older adults in berlin and in
singapore and compare it but also look
for the methodological difficulties in
applying something from from singapore
to germany and of course we then want to
do this as a groundwork to work later on
together in looking for interventions
can we do interventions maybe parallel
in berlin and in singapore to improve
and to prepare for healthcare for the
elderly and i think that's why i'm very
thankful that david and angelique took
their time in there now it's friday
evening already in singapore to present
their idea and their research and to
discuss with us and also paul gallard
from the institute of medical sociology
um so thank you very much for coming and
and presenting and discussing with us
maybe we can give a applause for you to
singapore i hope you can hear it over
there
and i also want to thank you all for
coming here and for the technical crew
for organizing it our first hybrid event
i think it worked quite well also there
were some minor things but that's always
happening so thank you very much for
this work thank you for coming and i
hope to see you soon in the one or the
other event and we are going to have
also workshops joint workshops with
singapore you're on your cordial be
invited to take part in them in the
spring and beginning of next year so
thank you all very much and have a nice
day or nice evening
[Applause]
[Music]
you